flattery has a bad name it's associated
with saying something upbeat
but untrue in order to hoodwink an
unsuspecting target for low personal
gain in Aesop's famous fable the Fox and
the crow an ugly crow has found a piece
of cheese and retired to a branch to eat
it a Sly Fox wanting it for himself
flatters the crow calling it beautiful
and wondering whether its voice will be
as sweet as its appearance the crow lets
out a horrific screeching sound and of
cheese drops straight into the fox's
gaping expectant mocking jewel but
there's another form of flattery with a
more valuable and ethical ambition
parents of small children invariably
discover its uses which deserve to be
better known and better practiced around
all age groups let's imagine that a
child isn't yet entirely kind to their
little brother or good at drawing or a
perfect cook or helpful around the house
but the parent declares that they are so
is to encourage and make more concrete
what is and yet only tentative and
fragile in their ambivalent nature the
child is being helped to end up as some
of the things he or she has already been
described as being in 1956 the Brazilian
architect Oscar Niemeyer was invited to
create a new capital city for his nation
what became Brasilia Brazil is a country
of frenetic economic activities of
rainforests that are alien villages
favelas cyclists beaches and intense
disagreement about political priorities
none of which is apparent from the
contemplation of the beautiful serene
futuristic and rational architecture of
Brasilia one day the building's proposed
Brazil will be a place where rationality
is powerful where order and harmony
reign where elegance is normal there
will be no more corruption or chaos in
offices efficient secretaries will type
up judicious briefing notes a filing
systems will be perfect nothing will get
lost overlooked neglected or mislaid
country could be perfectly managed Oscar
Niemeyer's capital is an essay in
flattery it hints that certain desirable
qualities which are as yet only very
latent in Brazil could one day be
central to the country and its governing
class shortly after the capital
buildings were completed a journalist
asked Niemeyer why he had designed a
capital that was so dramatically
unlike the country it was meant to
represent it won't be one day said
Niemeyer with a wry smile Brazilians
continued to wait for that day and the
finest buildings of Brasilia continue to
inspire we need flattery because we so
badly needs to be guided to develop
beyond what we are right now we need
other people's belief in us to bolster
our capacities for reform and growth we
need a chance to grow into the person we
have flatteringly been described as
already being consider a painting by
Velazquez the surrender of Breda
there's been a battle between Spain and
the Netherlands Spain has won the
picture shows the Spanish general
Spinoza receiving the key to the city of
Breda from the representative of the
defeated Dutch forces Justin of Nassau
what's striking is how cordial
everything is historians report that
both sides behaved extremely well there
was no recrimination or wanton bloodshed
the painting is a memorial to unusually
noble conduct but it's not of course a
comprehensive or accurate account of war
or sieges but just as Brasilia is not
the completely accurate representation
of what Brazil is like instead each of
these works presents an ideal in the
hope of generating a subsequent reality
we should learn to be gentler on
flattery and the energy it can lend us
to move towards greater generosity
intelligence and wisdom we should use
its benign power in order to bring about
a world where we'll more often be able
soon
to praise one another and no longer
merely just to flatter we believe in
making the world a more emotionally
intelligent place and to that end we've
now also published some extraordinary
books as well as other merchandise that
reinforces some of the themes
illustrated in our videos please click
on the link below to see more